this part of what makes us human is the
ability for us to be angry to cry and
more than anything to have these
pro-social emotions that's what's
contagious right so when I talk about in
the book The reason I talk about ah
having ah again is that's what actually
gives us hope so for me like numbers and
how we're going to move into a future
and Escape certain things that could add
demise
is good and interesting but what's
actually get I think and based on
Research kind of get a lot of folks up
in the morning is to be emotionally
connected to the Future
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to forward
futurist author of The Great Book long
path becoming the great ancestors our
future needs an antidote for
short-termism and TV host of the
upcoming PBS series a brief history of
the future are you walek welcome Ari
thanks for having me wow I gotta say all
of us watching or listening to this
right now are thinking uh I always
wanted to be a futurist how the hell do
you become a futurist
hey you want to know the the story look
I it's interesting you don't necessarily
grow up and say I want to become a
futurist you kind of grow up trying to
figure out where kind of your passions
meet the needs of the world right
um and I have a kind of a interesting
background in the sense that like my
life story starts in the 1920s my dad
was born in Poland in a kind of small
little kind of Jewish settle and very
soon after the war that shuttle was made
even smaller and the the short version
of the story is he ended up escaping the
ghetto uh after his father and his two
brothers were killed by the Nazis his
mom and sister were sent to Auschwitz
and he escaped and joined the Jewish
underground and was kind of a commander
in the Jewish underground after the war
did Nazi hunting a whole bunch of stuff
through Cuba and Mexico where he met my
mom now my mom was a student of
Buckminster Fuller who was an architect
an engineer and a female hero of mine uh
I I take quotes from Buckminster Fuller
all the live longer Buck Mr Fuller
there's a lot to say one of the things
about image there's a lot of quotes
right and so I grew up in this home
where we would have dinners that the
kind of the the temporalness of dinners
we were talking about the news of the
day that's what we did five six nights a
week we ate together as a family but
because of my father's kind of History
going back really to the 1920s and my
mom sitting under Buckminster Fuller the
the time frame of those conversations
was always like 100 150 years so my dad
always kind of brought in the past so
whatever we were saying he would say
well you know if you want to understand
that you have to go back a few
Generations now my mom would flip it and
say well then where do we go with this
and she would go forward a few
Generations somewhere my dad was in the
1920s my mom was in the 2120s and that
was kind of how I was raised so it kind
of makes sense that I ended up kind of
going into something that basically that
that was an exemplified that big range
of time uh well certainly your your
family background is unique and
compelling does the fact that uh you had
a parent who worked for the legendary
book vidster Fuller
uh but still it seems like a difficult
field like how does one get into it I
mean in your case you studied uh you
wound up running an innovation lab you
did a TED Talk that's been seen millions
of times uh but like what was that path
like what's interesting so in the in the
I think it's interesting no one else may
think in the 1990s I went to UC Berkeley
and there was a smaller it's about there
oh my brother's named after the Lawrence
Hall of Science okay so I'm in the right
place so uh in the 1990s there was a
small little kind of organization
company in Emeryville kind of right next
to Berkeley called the global business
Network and gbn was not really known by
many people but those who knew it knew
what it was and it was like there's only
a company started by Peter Schwartz
Stuart brand of the whole earth catalog
a bunch of other folks and what they
basically did was kind of futuring for
large organizations and they were kind
of involved in everything from National
Security to political stuff to corporate
stuff it just so happened that they were
trying to kind of give these like Salon
talks while I was at Cal and I have no
idea you have but I got invited to
attend some of them so that's kind of my
first taste of understanding like you
can there are people who are focused on
the long term that's a Bay Area thing a
barrier thing well so and we'll get to
it in a sec because they came at it I
I'll say at least in my kind of
estimation very much kind of through a
technological lens right gbn the folks
that came with gbn actually Peter
Schwartz came from the scenario Planning
Group at Royal Dutch Shell so really
there weren't a lot of kind of real
working futurists uh up until gbn really
it was the people who were doing it were
probably the intelligence Community
Herman Khan at Rand was doing it and gbn
was doing it and if you've seen Minority
Report which most folks have well you
don't what most folks don't know is a
lot of what kind of happens in my own
report that kind of projects after the
future was actually put together by the
folks at gbn Walter Parks brought them
in and said okay here's kind of the plot
for this movie it's based off of Philip
K dick like how do we expand this how do
we create this world a bunch of the gbn
folks got together and created that now
that's a manifestation of future and
work that everyone gets to see a lot of
what gbn did no one got to see right and
so I was going to these salons and
really these folks that were talking
about not just the future but really
kind of what captivated me were these
Mega Trends was this idea that there
were these larger issues that went back
decades if not centuries that were
playing out today
um and because I was a peace and
conflict Studies major at UC Berkeley
studying major world conflict it kind of
kind of Drew me in and so over the years
as I read more kind of practiced more
and and learned about scenario planning
these kind of classic featuring
techniques I guess I became a futurist
so you did and we're grateful for it so
now you're the founder and executive
director of long Path Labs uh and
obviously this book long path
presents those ideas I enjoyed your book
a lot I think that anyone who reads it
will feel themselves striving to be more
long-term focused uh and and you make it
very personal uh but what was
interesting to me was that that that it
it had this Zen spirituality feeling to
it it's like look whatever's bothering
you right now like is it that big a deal
yes in the Long Haul yep so like so so I
mentioned this you mentioned the bay
area so I I went to UC Berkeley in the
Bay Area so while I was doing this kind
of formal academic work at Berkeley and
hanging out with all these features
Monday through Friday on the weekends I
was going to Green Gulch which was kind
of the the San Francisco Zen Center's
farm so I was kind of going to Dharma
talks and Zen talks and doing that part
of my life right and and I say that part
because I there's kind of a bifurcation
in my 20s I was like during the day kind
of a futurist and working with really
kind of the precursors to you know big
Tech and big data but on the weekends I
was doing something totally different it
was it was a it was a way of kind of
bringing at least sotozen which is kind
of the Japanese version of of kind of
thinking about the world and suffering
and at the Eightfold Path that was my
weekend and I kind of had those
separated
probably for like two decades of the
work that I was doing and I realized
really around 2015 when I was doing a
lot of this kind of
corporate featuring work that it made
sense especially during the 2016
election I realized these worlds not
only should not be kept separate but we
actually had to find a way to combine
them so it's interesting a lot of people
who who read this book are like oh if
they're coming as kind of from the
featuring space they say there's this
really Zen spiritual quality then
there's people who are coming from this
Zen spiritual space who are also my
people we're like oh I never even
thought about the future in this way and
so this book is the kind of melding of
those two worlds yeah I I love the fact
that you made it real and relatable uh
in that way I think your idea about the
official future is very interesting and
Powerful where right now most people
when they think about the future uh
don't have a great feeling about it
nowadays uh and one of the quotes you
have is that only an examined future is
worth fighting for which I appreciated a
great deal so do you want to walk
through the cone of Futures I'll walk
through the kind of features but what
I'm going to do is I'm going to kind of
like set the table please for that so
one of the things I talk about in the
book is this idea of the intertidal
um and so an intertidal in marine
ecosystems is that place that sometimes
above water sometimes below water and so
when I look at where we are as a society
and when I'm when I say sorry I really
mean planetary kind of where Homo
sapiens are at I'm making an argument
that we are in this intertidal moment
we're kind of in between what was and
what will be so uh you know you've
probably heard of the term interregnum
which is in between two pubes so we're
in this intertidal what's amazing about
intertidal both uh in in the Marine
sense and in the sense of where we are
right now is all it's like it can go
either way right the way I think of
inner title is It's a transition point
it's a transition period but it's not
unlike the the intertidal in the Marine
system where basically the tide will
come in and out we're actually not sure
which way this one will go
now the last kind of
there's been many inter titles I think
over human history the last kind of
really big one at least from my
perspective is from Hunter gather to
agricultural so 10 to 10 to 12 000 years
ago
and what what kind of signifies an
intertidal isn't just like a
technological shift it's really about a
mindset shift that is that is predicated
on new narratives and new ways of being
it's really kind of how we view the
world
and when you described the forces that
are driving this uh transition period
um so one was definitely technological
but but the other is the fact that it
seems like our current institutions uh
aren't up to snuff but not up to Snuff
and more so the way we kind of know that
we can we can argue back and forth are
they are there are they not but the fact
is when we step back and we look at
people's trust in those institutions and
we could argue that some of that
empirically trust is declining very very
fast empirically right and so and look
we could argue well how are you measure
the institutions just aren't up here now
that doesn't mean you throw the baby out
with a bath water right part of the
issue I I argue in this book is that we
threw the baby out with the bath water
about 400 years ago right as we
transitioned from the Renaissance into
the Enlightenment and we move to a kind
of scientific
analytical hyper analytical National way
of seeing the world the scientific
method which is amazing but as we move
to that and you kind of alluded this
earlier we also completely threw out the
spiritual we threw about the emotional
if everything was zero one in binary
either in or out black and white now
that wasn't necessarily terrible right
but that's how you from if we look at
bacon and we look at kind of these the
folks that kind of gave us the
enlightenment we need to go through that
moment to kind of understand the world
as it was part of it was to counter the
power of the church right which was kind
of dictating
everything the narratives the way we see
that we saw the world so in some ways we
kind of see this this pendulum swing to
the hyper rational because the spiritual
and emotional is out here and it can be
we can be controlled and it's controlled
by others especially when it comes to
issues like your death and how how what
you do in your life whether you go to
heaven or hell is dictated by the church
so like that was a lot of that had a lot
of power over us so we have this
transition to the hyper rational to The
Logical so now here we are at this part
of you know Homo sapiens the 2020s and
the internet how would you define what
the heck we're going through now we're
going through where we're kind of trying
again trying to counter balance on the
one hand we need kind of binary in
science and it gave us technology gave
us our phones it gave us these
microphones right you couldn't develop
the technology for what we're doing
right now on these lights and the
internet through an overly romantic you
know theological way of seeing the world
we needed it the problem is how systems
work how human system works how
political system works isn't binary
right it's kind of zero one maybe and
anyone who's kind of following Quantum
will realize that there's a strong
corollary right so we're seeing the kind
of decline of binary thinking this inner
out or we could argue two-party systems
right one or left in the right so
something that's maybe Left Right
synthesis middle which again kind of
mirrors where we are with Quantum
Computing not trying to stretch the
metaphor but that's where we are right
now people are realizing the
institutions this way of seeing the
world isn't working right so in the
hyper rational Uber capitalism way of
seeing a forest for instance as a
capitalist I'll see the forest and I see
lumber yard I'm like oh I could get 37
million dollars from that Forest right
from a kind of systems way of looking at
a more kind of humanistic way of looking
at a long pathway of looking at it its
assistant provides clean air clean water
habitat yes we need trees to build but
it can't just be that so it's a yes no
maybe right and so we're in this
intertidal moment
guess what just came out on paperback
it's forward out on October 4th you can
buy it in any bookstore near you and if
you use the promo code Yang you get
absolutely nothing this is your chance
if you are waiting for a cheaper version
of the book is that October 4th
pre-order it I really am proud of this
book uh it's something that you have to
read to believe all right forward out on
paperback thank you everyone
[Music]
foreign
and so when when you were if you were to
Define long path uh and the approach uh
how would you do so
so
this goes back to one of your earliest
questions
um those of us kind of came up through
futuring it was kind of an overly
intellectual kind of cognitive thing
right like you'd go into a room a lot of
Post-it notes you do scenario planning
you think your way through it
what I realized was and this goes to
kind of the the Buddhist change of my
20s and kind of ongoing is where we get
into trouble and where Futures get into
trouble in general is when we say this
is the answer this is the way to do it
it's it's kind of the Zero Sum so when I
kind of surveyed what was out there in
the kind of future in literature A lot
of it was very kind of predictive like
this is going to be the future get on
board or don't it's going to be this and
if it's not this if it's not this
official future this official future as
kind of dictated by Futures you have no
hope of surviving and it was kind of a
and again not knocking away well I ran
into this a lot when I was running for
president when people would ask me all
the time uh what should I tell my kids
to study because one of my arguments was
look technology AI are going to be
transforming work in a way that's going
to make it so that certain things that
might have made sense another another
time uh and one of the reasons I was
doing what I was doing was what your
suggestion testing which is look there's
no reason we need to accept a vision or
version of the future as given it's like
maybe we could get together and say you
know what you want something else and so
wait so people come up to me all the
time sure what should my kids learn in
college and what I I always say the same
thing I go it's not necessarily what
they should learn they need to learn how
to learn and how to kind of relearn and
question these assumptions especially
around official narratives and official
features right so I'm getting to the
voros cone right and so what long path
is is an applied mindset so when you
kind of go through the book you really
see the book and you you read it the
book exists on two layers there's kind
of the cognitive intellectual academic
like here's where we are here's how
here's how to think here's kind of how
the world can be looked at in this way
there's a second part so in every
chapter there are these questions these
almost like workbook questions
those workbook questions by the way I
learned that in my 20s right it's about
kind of going through an embodied
process to shift your mindset so so long
path is a is really is that it's a
mindset it's a way of seeing people who
have read the book are like look I I get
it in that I see everything very
differently now and that's what a
mindset is so the argument that I'm
making the kind of sub Rose argument in
the book is we need a different way of
thinking in this intertidal if we want
to successfully navigate it yeah there
was a review of the book and someone
said oh the book was great but it was
terrible because it didn't tell us what
the future was it didn't tell me what I
need to do right what it was going to be
what stocks to buy because that's the
old mindset right it's like this is what
I invest in this is the this is what my
kids should study this specific field
I'm making an argument and then walking
through people walking people through
steps of saying this is how you can
think differently in this moment to make
it successfully through but because you
don't have a crystal ball I'm not saying
to make it successfully through to
anything specific except kind of these
features that we want so that's how I
describe long path as this mindset the
the the the applied mindset
of long path you there's kind of three
pillars on it and the first pillar this
idea it's obvious we already tacked it
is Futures thinking future with an S
right so I get probably like you invited
to speak on these panels all the time
the future singular of X yeah and I
refuse to go on those panels unless they
add an S to it and I always get these
kind of strange little y's and S and I
go because we can't if we're actually
saying the future of education is X then
we are limiting ourselves so this idea
of the voros cone this future is voros
right who uh for his last name is voros
is this idea that we kind of
in society live in this official future
it's kind of if we think about it as a
you'll see in the book it's kind of this
like an ice cream we all we all know
it's all shape named after us you could
have the Wallach pyramid I could have
the Yang cylinder yeah
so black Mr Fuller took took that you
know 10 security structure of the dome
but I would like something that's more
systems right like the wall of mesh
right um yes and so
the official future is how we operate as
Homo sapiens like we've always had it we
we've always probably look I wasn't
there 10 10 12 000 years ago what I can
say is as I look at history it's it's
cognitively taxing to not know in any
way shape or form what tomorrow will
bring we have to have kind of a sense of
it especially as a society so we can
kind of order ourselves and build these
institutions
so the official future right now is very
at least in the in the global North and
the West it's very much a Silicon Valley
dictated official future it's like it's
all technology it's all Quantum it's all
ever it's what we call kind of techno
solutionism or even techno-utopianism or
if you want to really push it out kind
of towards the singularity transhumanism
that's this idea this official future
that we all operate in is that it's only
about technology now parts of what I
agree with parts of it I don't but what
I can tell you is this official feature
whether you look at it through kind of
the narrow lens of just technology or a
slightly broader of kind of these old
western kind of top-down binary
institutions it's not working anymore
and which or at least to the extent that
there is an official future it's not
when people are excited about it it's
not what people are excited about and so
there's so there's interesting because
there's there's that kind of utopian
official future right which is Tech will
solve everything and we will live in
this thing and then maybe we'll have
Universal basic income maybe we'll have
I mean you know which by the way I'm a
fan of obviously
uh yeah so there's a continuous there's
a techno-utopian version well there's
also a dystopian version yeah right in
close in reality but you know so and
there's an issue with the dystopian
version because in fact that official
future is all we've seen media right so
I was
so I have 13 year old twin daughters and
I was kind of looking for their bookcase
a couple of years ago and all these
novels that are geared towards kind of
young adults teenagers tweens in every
single book that had to do with the
future five years out 30 years out
whether it's Hunger Games or Insurgent
every single one of them was dystopian
every single one of them that looked out
was a terrible tomorrow that more often
than not was terrible because there had
been some sort of cataclysmic event it
could be nuclear war whatever it was
something terrible had happened
and I and I realized oh my God this is
what we are doing to an entire
generation when we talk about tomorrow
we either say it's going to be kind of
transhumanistic Singularity that
technology will solve everything or it's
going to be horrific but there's nothing
different there's kind of no maybe
there's no agency the future is going to
wash over you either you'll eventually
be uploaded or you're going to be
fighting for your summer with with
Spears that's it that those are kind of
the two official feature narratives that
we're putting out for the next
generation and that we're all existing
in right yes and so what I argue in the
book with Futures is just to kind of
open that aperture and say maybe maybe
there's a third way or a fourth way or a
fifth way and how we get there is I
argue is by having a different kind of
more adaptable mindset which is long
path
you know one thing that has uh motivated
me for the last five years I was in one
of these conferences and there's a panel
and there was a journalist on the stage
and she said why does it feel like we're
on a path off a cliff but no one can do
anything about it yeah and I heard that
and I said she's right that is what it
feels like and it is energized and
motivated me ever since because I'm like
why the [ __ ] can't we actually improve
our future like do we really have to
just accept
uh automation or climate change or
dysfunction or polarization or whatever
it happens to be
um so I'm with you in the fact that
there are multiple paths and we should
do everything we can to try and like get
on one that we're we're happier about uh
the the prescription you have
um is a fascinating one because it is
much more about mindset than about what
a lot of people probably ask you for all
the time which is okay what are the
steps and I I confess I'm a steps guy
yep so so now I'm like you know what we
can use right choice voting so that we
actually get like improve the incentives
for legislators
um but one one of the fascinating things
for me is that the mindset thing is
familiar to me in the sense that on the
presidential I was always arguing that
we have uh either a mindset of abundance
or mindset of scarcity and that uh most
of American life now operates on the
scarcity model
that that this will eventually eat Us
Alive and that we need to convert to the
abundance model uh as quickly as we can
yeah like the the
what I'm arguing for in terms of having
a kind of a long path mindset isn't like
oh having this mindset is the answer
remarkable is having this mindset
actually opens the aperture of what is
possible so I I love ranked Choice
voting but there's there's very few of
us who think ranked Choice voting is
good or interesting more often than not
it's treated like a traffic circle oh a
great idea but it's too complicated no
one will get it the fact of the matter
is is having a different mindset that
isn't locked into a zero-som binary way
of thinking is kind of tilling the soil
kind of opens people up to this idea
that there is a different way so I you
know as as I I'm not able to do those
kind of random control trial right but
I'd love to do we're getting I'd love to
get 100 people 50 of them we kind of
take them into the long path mindset and
50 of them is a control group and then
we introduce traffic circles or ranked
Choice voting right and because both of
those are kind of similar in some way
there's a different way of doing it it's
not start stop it's they're very similar
but if you have this kind of more
adaptable kind of this mindset the long
pathy and mindset I think that opens you
up to different ideas and ways of doing
things and seeing different paths
towards different Futures yeah you use
examples of a woman who has to decide
how to build a track at a school or a
village trying to decide how to repair a
bridge and one of the things you ask for
people to do is to retreat and say okay
what is the real Point yeah like what am
I actually trying to to achieve to get
themselves out of a particular trade-off
particularly uh money uh you know it's
like oh this will be cheaper so let me
do this
um and you also even apply it to
something like a family reunion
where it's like well the point of this
reunion is that people can come together
and experience joy and like Express
their appreciation for for the this
relative so let's try to stay focused on
on that out as a goal as opposed to
let's get on the big picture right it's
funny we just had kind of a dual bot mix
for our for our daughters and I look I
wrote the book on this and I got caught
up like oh who's coming to the party
what's the party I got caught up on this
you know the subline of it is an
antidote for short-termism I got caught
up in the short-termism of the moment
right short-termism isn't a terrible
thing right if
if R and Andrew 15 000 years ago are
walking in the center and getting a huge
animal comes out you and I should run we
should uh
our amygdala should activate our limbic
system we should get pumping with
adrenaline we should run we should be
short-term
the fact of the matter is we live in a
part part of being in a title is an
amped up Amplified short-termistic
Tendencies because again we don't have
this idea of a feature we want so we get
kind of overly kind of caught up in the
moment and we just become highly
reactive now fold into that the the
dopamine machine that is social media
and we have a recipe for hyper
short-termism and so when we look at
ranked Choice voting are these different
ways we want to move forward as a as
individuals as a country as a planetary
civilization we're only going to look at
short-term fixes what I call kind of a
sandbag strategy in the book right
because we're looking for that if if you
look at where we are politically right
now and what's happened especially on
the right people are looking and
attracted to someone right now who's
giving them a sense of an official
future now it's a retrograde future
about going back to a a perceived Glory
day but at least it's a vision of the
future where they can see themselves in
it right and so this becomes the issue
look let's be totally clear
we're we're always asking ourselves
basically two questions existential
questions like who am I and why am I
here and so if we think about kind of
policies and politics and how we go
about answering those questions anyone
who can answer who you are and why
you're here will always win the day
the argument in the book is that's not
enough that's a very short-term mistake
I way of doing it the the bigger way of
doing it that we should be thinking
about as a species Homo sapiens is who
are we and why are we here and so when
you talk about the book this kind of
personal way of like why are we doing it
it can't just be for these kind of
Quantified metrics of the moment of this
of a family reunion and making sure the
party gets goes off right because the
look
you know like you I've been in a lot of
these very quote unquote like powerful
rooms I've been in the United States the
situation and the security Council these
are all like clients these are people
who I've worked with right
there's only a few thousand people on
the planet ever actually get to be in
these rooms and influence in these rooms
yet there's billions of us so the
question is what do we do well we can
vote a certain way we can consume a
certain way and those are always just
kind of the only two choices we've been
giving I'm adding the third choice we
can behave a certain way why the way we
behave and I open the everyone expecting
me to open the book with a big thing
about The Marshall Project or Panama big
futuristic thing I opened the book a
story about my daughter in a missed
homework assignment and how I chose to
react between the action and the
reaction right there's kind of that
stimulus moment
in a hyper short-termistic time the way
we're going to react more often not is
for me to yell at my daughter or for me
to say oh the standard Union has to look
this certain way and not think about the
bigger picture because the way we behave
models a set of actions in this moment
between let's say Ari and Andrew but I
but when we think about it emotions are
highly contagious and emotions are these
reactions that we have more often than
not if we think about the the reactions
and the emotions we have at any given
moment as actually not just about the
moment but about having long-term
ramifications so the way you and I may
react right now will change how you act
as someone downstairs we actually start
building these uh emotional heirlooms
that we pass down to Generations that's
how we start to impact the long-term
future sure vote a certain way consume a
certain way but also act a certain way
because that's how we actually start
changing the future now some people hear
that and say that's totally new age it
doesn't matter we have to we have to
vote these people out of office but a
hundred percent
we like trillions of dollars is at stake
right here whether we have nuclear
weapons or nuclear power or regenerative
or ranked Choice voting matters I'm not
taking that away but for most of us
myself included how I go about acting
with other humans the rest of my day
will actually impact the future in a way
much bigger than we think right so I
meet people all the time probably like
you do these amazing people in policy or
politicians that have great big ideas
that are going to save the world
but when you kind of this is not all of
them but you need they're not nice
people they have terrible relationships
with their family well one of the
reasons why they and some some of them
are you know great but a lot of them are
not nice
um but part of it is because of the uh
machine that they're a part of or the
incentive structure and you reference
social media as rewarding short-termism
which I totally agree yeah
and so I think that there's this massive
amplifier to some of the the negative uh
tendencies that we have to think that
you're always on the run so to speak
um and reading your story about you and
your daughter I mean as a parent myself
like I could relate and I it made me a
better parent for about a day yeah and I
was like you know I mean the book
generally just made me like think
um more uh both long term and also in a
more elevated way yeah and when I'm in a
good State I think that that's like my
operating mode yep um and then when I'm
in a bad State less so
and it feels like they're all of these
forces that are pushing people toward a
bad State and rewarding people for it
yep and and so the so if I agree with uh
your thesis is that hey we should also
try and behave a certain way and then
the behavior will end up opening up
possibilities of us maybe making better
long-term things happen or maybe making
our kids stronger or healthier
individuals and you know agree with
um I also feel like there's this uh you
know again like force multiplier on the
other side
and so my natural thought is like what
could be like the force multiplier on
like the the other side yeah I mean look
there's a reason much to the Chagrin of
my teenage daughters they're not on
social media because it's not them
happier it's not them up against an app
or a company they're up against the
forced multiplier of massive AI built
server Farms who are solely focused and
this is you know I I worked with these
companies so it's not like I'm not
blaming evil Engineers but they're
solely focused in a in a hyper Western
third stage capitalistic way of doing a
value extraction
from my daughters and that's what
they're up against and so you know
they're saying oh all my friends are on
it I said it's okay I understand that
but at the same time it's not it's it's
you against an army of some of the most
amazing brilliant computer scientists
the planet has ever built who are
literally trying to figure out how to
capture you and keep you on there as
much as possible and reward you in such
a way that you constantly kind of keep
coming back and keep you know they say
we check our for our email 20 times a
day right people who are on Tick Tock or
other platforms are checking 50 100 150
times a day they're checking their phone
even when they have notifications set up
we look to be totally clear
I am a romantic about humans but I also
see us as very smart primates like the
system this is this is great but we're
not as like all that as we think we are
it's not that difficult to hack the
hardware here right there aren't a lot
and to your point there aren't a lot of
firewalls between us and these Force
multipliers and the fourth multiple
obviously are technology and I'm not I'm
not a Luddite but what I'm saying is how
we design these overarching systems and
this goes to the the third pillar of
long path we'll get back to the second
one but this idea of kind of an ultimate
aim what I call Telos in the book right
this is this idea that's the point what
is the point of this like would it and
that becomes a question right like what
is the point of this bot Mitzvah party
what is the point of this family mean
what is the point of this company right
I was just researching companies there's
you can go on Wikipedia there's there's
about a thousand companies that have
been around over a thousand years right
most of them are based in Japan no
surprise
um and in different parts of Europe
but what is the point of those mostly
privately held companies is the
long-term flourishing of the Enterprise
the communities they live in and
ensuring the kind of the family has
somewhere to go to work over several
generations and so the question is what
if we decided to kind of order our
society like that around a bigger old a
bigger goal or aim like what is the
point because the fact is
the the American let's just take the
American dream right the picket fence
all that like highly unattainable for
most people because of the kind of the
rampant inequality of the way the system
is built the way capitalism is built
right now
um but if we were kind of and I and look
I'm all for uh stakeholder capitalism or
shareholder cut that's a competition we
have to have and luckily people are much
smarter than me are having that
conversation but the step back is like
again like to what end right so if if we
think Homo sapiens are going to be
around for a while which hopefully they
will be we all will be in one way or
another the question becomes like what
why is it because and by the way there's
a lot of people who will answer that and
say well this this Hardware this this
body with a spleen and appendix and all
these things that can go wrong
that's actually just like version one
version two or three is we upload
Consciousness and get away with this
like I understand those folks I am not
one of those folks like I think who we
are warts and all literally
metaphorically with emotion sadness
crying like that's what makes it
beautiful so the question is if you're
so so if if you subscribe to that thesis
that we should stay in these bodies
and we want to move forward over the
next several thousand years the question
is to what end like what do we want this
to be what what kind of world do we want
to set up for our descendants right
there's this big fallacy that uh Gilbert
talks about this at Harvard kind of the
the end of History fallacy that Ari and
Andrew are at the kind of bleeding edge
of how far we can go as a species like
this is it like you know we have clothes
if this is as far as it goes we're in
some trouble but that's the issue we
we're kind of convinced this as far as
it goes so so so
you can't tell now but in high school I
ran track right I was on I did two
sports I did pole vaulting and I did uh
the 4x100 relay and what I learned about
the 400 4x100 relay is everyone could
put a bunch of fast Runners you can put
everyone you know you get four really
fast folks on the track where you win
and lose these races is in this
transition zone where you're handing the
Baton off or really in the intertidal
zone
and so it's unbelievably important right
now is in those four by one hundred
relay races we know what the Telos is
win the race right the anchor Runner has
to cross the finish line ahead of the
other people but here's the thing like
there is no Finish Line in this home
what I call the project it's kind of
homo sapien bigger than we are we hope
that's not a Finish Line well we hope
there's on a Finish Line look most
mammals at least on Earth last about a
million years before there's kind of a
die off so if we say okay we're maybe
150 to 200 000 years into this as Homo
sapiens we have at least 800 000 years
but that's that's assuming we kind of
stay on the planet and blah blah
we could have a million to three million
years left in us if not more so what are
and Andrew do today yes in terms of
climate change in terms of politics
these things actually matter my argument
is what what also matters is what kind
of humans are we going to be
foreign
do you see your relationship with uh
um effective altruism and uh will
mccaskill
uh whom I had dinner with last month
delightful uh you know so they are
trying to build a movement uh you know
when you talk about the contrast and the
way I'd summarize effective altruism is
trying to do as much good as possible
for as many people as possible taking
future humans into account yeah which
means that if I prevent climate change
then it's not just the people who are
here it's the folks for the next 500 000
800 000 years and your your book did
remind me of that line of thought you
guys have different approaches and
emphases
um I enjoy them both
uh you I mean you cited him at least
once in the book like you guys friendly
and yeah friendly I think it's it's
complementary I think they're they're
the emphasis of effective altruism as
far as I know and I have friends who are
like EA or EA adjacent right is is
really one of like in some ways about
running the numbers right if we kind of
like step back and say okay what's the
most good we can do right now and and as
I when I talk to my friends in EA I say
how what what is the most you can do
right now outside of like you know how
you vote and how you consume and what
they'll say is at least what they've
said to me is what it's how you donate
like where do you put your your your
time and your money especially around
things like existential risk like things
that can kind of end Homo sapiens in the
near term so
I like that it's good where I think the
I don't think the Divergence is but what
the layer that long path adds is how you
are in this moment to moment actually
matters and I don't know if I don't
think Wilderness like argue with me but
what I'm going to kind of push very
heavy on is how you are a human in the
moment to moment to others and yourself
uh matters right so so in the book I
talk about kind of the second pillar of
long past we did Futures thinking and we
did tilos kind of ultimate name in the
middle I talk about transgenerational
empathy right so where this differs with
a lot of folks who kind of think about
the future is I'm going to re-center
emotions right whereas other people will
say like we have to kind of Drive
emotions out we have to kind of be hyper
rational because emotions makes things
messy and sticky I'm actually gonna say
no no no we have to invite emotions back
in not because uh emotions need to be
invited back in so that when you see
kind of these infomercials at night with
children in other parts of the world
you're going to give more money because
it's and it may not be an effective
thing to give to for the long-term I'm
talking about that I'm talking about
like emotional in that way what I'm
saying is
this part of what makes us human is the
ability for us to be angry to cry and
more than anything to have these
pro-social emotions that's what's
contagious right so when I talk about in
the book The reason I talk about ah
having ah again is that's what actually
gives us hope so for me like numbers and
how we're going to move into a future
and Escape certain things that could add
demise
is good and interesting but what's
actually get I think and based on
Research kind of get a lot of folks up
in the morning is to be emotionally
connected to the Future right this is so
let's go back and talk about what
transgenerational empathy is so kind of
we know there's empathy there's
cognitive empathy something Andrew's
doing a certain way and I can kind of
intellectually understand that sadness
and there's a kind of affect of empathy
which is like being there with you now
some will say what does it have to do
with the future
my argument is that being Ari and Andrew
being there together in that space
lays a foundational layer for the kind
of humans we want to be right so when I
when I think about like these far
Futures I like many people who are kind
of Futures we look at Star Trek right
sure I'm a fan yeah especially the Next
Generation right yeah and so there's a
kind of a Spokane future right which is
like overly logical and overly hyper
rational but when you step back and say
like what makes Spock so special is this
idea that he was you know half Vulcan
half human that emotional side and so
what long path does is bring us back
into a way where we can be empathic and
have empathy uh transgenerationally so
let me let me break let me tease that
out for a second
first and foremost it's having empathy
for the past and there there's one kind
of um subversive reason that is because
just to be clear and I say this in the
book but I'm going to read along for
people or read ahead for folks is you
are somebody's past
and the way we look at the past right
now tends to be kind of very judgmental
we tend to view folks in the past and I
I don't have to get the big I don't
think make this political the way we
view our parents or our grandparents
we're like how could they do that what
were they thinking
right and and it can be things that are
really horrific like Germany something
that's very close to me or it could just
be the way like my parents used to fight
with one another like we all no one grew
up in in Shangri-La but the fact of the
matter is everyone does the best with
what they have at the time right I often
think about this
and the example I give is and you know a
couple hundred years from now people are
gonna be shocked that we ate animals
right I'm not a vegetarian but I'm sure
at one point we will realize how
probably terrible it is when we somehow
figure out their Consciousness and their
pain and people will look back and be
like barbarians or if we you just have
synthetic proteins that do the same
thing with the suffering without the
suffering so we'll have that but they'll
say well how you know how did are you go
how they do it with the stuff how did
they do it I had a hamburger last night
how could he have done that like again a
transgenerational empathy isn't about
letting people off the hook in the past
it's recognizing that they were doing
the best they could at that given point
in time okay so that's empathy with the
past what that allows you to do is to
move into empathy with the present so
that's really about kind of
self-awareness and self-compassion this
is the when I talk about long path being
a way that we can kind of create better
Futures this is kind of the both the the
slicing of the gordian knot and the most
biggest stumbling block because and I've
done this before if you take a bunch of
folks and say let's talk about tomorrow
what do you want the future to look like
what is your desired future this goes
back to the Voris cone they'll say oh my
desired future is I have a big house and
you know all these things because that
is what society and media and their
parents and everyone has said this is
what you this is this is what you desire
an official future that's your desired
official feature but in the book
stop there I go to the next which is
exam and desired feature the way you
have an examined desired feature is to
examine yourself and a level of
self-awareness about what got you here
right Marshall Goldsmith has this great
coaching book what got you here won't
get you there it's for new CEOs I apply
the same thing to individuals but to
society what God is here won't get us
there so if we want to think about these
better Futures if we don't examine what
got us to this point and say you know
what
maybe Andrew isn't perfect maybe Ari
isn't perfect we have some work to do on
ourselves that does two amazing things
one it opens us up to thinking about
kind of better tomorrows where we're not
taking the baggage from the past into
our decision making Matrix which we
always do I've been running
corporate off-sites for 20 years large
organizational uh off sites I'll say
well why do you guys do it that way and
they say the ones that before us did it
that way and they they did it that way
so first of all that level of
self-understanding what I picked up in
my 20s being at the green Gulch and
doing a lot of mindfulness-based
meditation was examining how I got to
this point doesn't mean you get a clean
slate No One's Gonna I'm not arguing for
everyone to become like the Dalai Lama
and be perfect in that way but it's kind
of say like why do I make decisions that
way because and I know by the way I
still do this right I was trying to make
a decision about something for for my
work and my career just three days ago
and when I kind of kind of stepped back
I was like oh my God so much of that is
coming from like my ego or how I define
success or all these things that I grew
up with well if you hit the fast forward
button far enough not only are we having
empathy for our descendants uh hundreds
of years from now but we're also just
dust we just dashed right and so
you've done that now it's about empathy
for future Generations why why am I
arguing to have an emotional connection
to my great great grandchildren or even
humans that I won't even know in 2250
here's why everything we know about kind
of COG about Neuroscience cognitive
Neuroscience is I can say Andrew we have
to do all these policies this is the
most effective Thing This is Our
obligation of the future it's kind of a
PowerPoint but we have to do it this way
you and I will not we'll say yeah we
have to do it but then we won't like
there's no there's nothing kind of one
of the most interesting facts from your
book was that people's policy changes if
you actually have someone represent
future people at the meeting in the in
the room
episode would be like hey guys I'm I'm
you know humans from the winter when
they're in the room and I'll get to that
exam when they're in the room you have
an empathic emotional connection with
them so what what a mo what empathy does
it's like a you know a kedge like a
kedge anchor so a cage on a boat is an
anchor that you throw maybe 30 feet off
into the distance it sink takes the
ground and then you use a rope to kind
of pull you forward so what emotions do
is act as a cage anchor for the actions
that we have to take today on behalf of
future Generations so the way you become
a great ancestor is by taking actions
that hook that future up so you notice
what transgenerational empathy then does
is it does two things it makes you a
better human today literally in the
interactions you have with people
outside with your partners with your
colleagues with everyone that you meet
that's a huge plus because already that
starts to reverberate out over time one
two what actually comes with things like
ranked Choice voting or traffic circles
or things around climate change whatever
it is homelessness poverty
when you have an empathic emotional
connection with those future Generations
it's no longer a cognitive intellectual
hyper rational I should do this for this
by the way that can work for summary for
some folks but all the research shows
and there's a whole bunch of research in
this book by people on the long path
Labs Advisory Board Hal hirschfield UCLA
and David to stand out Northeastern
Jameel Zack and a bunch of other folks
it's actually that emotional anchoring
that allows you to make those decisions
on behalf of future Generations we know
this intuitively as parents we're
connected to our children and we will do
things that we call sacrifices on their
behalf because we're emotionally
connected to them by Birthright what
long path asks us to do is have that
same emotional connection to those who
aren't necessarily our children
[Music]
foreign
it's a profound perspective switch
and it made me think because I'm very
practical it made me think that uh
future humans need a Lobby
[Laughter]
yeah well so
the long-term Lobby
so in up until the heck you even call it
long pathology watch so a little bit of
backstory so uh from 2008 to 2000 really
16 17 I was running a company called
synthesis Corp we built kind of
foresight future labs for large
organizations probably the biggest was a
U.N Refugee agency so we're really
helping them think about well
we have the Syria crisis right now but
we know regardless of whatever we do
with kind of certain policies around
climate change and energy we're probably
going to have tens if not hundreds of
millions of climate refugees
so how do we kind of prepare
uh the organization and the country and
the World At Large to kind of think
about that and act in those policies now
2016 2017 happens we have this little
kind of this election
and I give this Ted Talk long path
because I had I was developing this this
mindset but it was kind of one of those
things you do off the side of your desk
because
not many people want you to be working
on 50 to 100 Year a thousand year
problems right they're you're being
hired to work on things you know getting
paid for five to ten years is a is a
privilege a luxury and an honor and I
was excited to be doing it but after I
gave the Ted Talk and after the election
cycle some philanthropists and other
folks came together and they said listen
how about you think about it this way
what if those alive in 21 well it was
back then it was 21-16 but you know 21
to 16 100 150 years from now if they can
go back and hire you
right so it's kind of a reverse Ministry
of the future like if they could go back
and hire you are you walking your
organization to work on their behalf
what would you do
right what would you do in an ethical
moral way to kind of hook those future
Generations up
and so I thought about it and that's
where the long that's where long path
went from a maybe kind of a an
intellectual Ted Talk type exercise into
something much deeper much more
um
embodied as a practice right as a
mindset that it wasn't meant to replace
anything it was me look I I've gotten a
lot of amazing emails from from rabbis
and Priests and Iman saying I love your
book I'm using it in the work that I'm
doing I've also got it from CEOs I've
gotten from a lot of parents a lot of
teachers a lot of folks saying I'm
bringing this mindset this practice into
the work that I do so I can be a better
human today I can be a better parent
today because I see things in a much
bigger frame so I have a much bigger to
what end and at the same time I'm also
being a great ancestor to Future
Generations it's kind of like a two for
one right you're you're better and
you're happier today it's interesting uh
uh Harbor Collins shell this under
happiness I was like how are you putting
this book under happiness this is a big
screen reading this did make me happier
so I thought it was going to be a book
about socially she's in terms and future
but because I came you know you're
always right right and and then people
are saying like oh it makes me happier
today which makes me happy because well
what I'm doing it tries to give you
perspective on the quotidian struggles
and your irritating child Behavior Uh
crisis of the moment and and you know
you think oh well what would Ari do or
he would try and zoom out how do I zoom
out that could be what it you know the
subtitle zoom out do you want to be
happier today in a way that hooks up
future Generations as well
make sure better it makes you a great
ancestor right I mean that's the longer
subtitle but that is what this is about
and that's what long Path Labs about I
mean so there's a book we work with
organizations we're going to be working
with the UN again like it it happens
this work happens on multiple layers but
the kind of again this this Foundation
this bottom of the pyramid if you want
if you will has to be a mindset has to
be a way of kind of seeing the world
with with new lenses so you're not stuck
I talk about this in the book you're not
stuck in the kind of classic trap of
well what is the good and the right
thing to do based on these bookends of
from Ari's birth to Ari's death right
this kind of lifespan bias that locks us
into making decisions in a certain way
with the book and the mindset do is it
kind of pulls you out of that yeah
you are important but a whole bunch of
lives came before you and there's a
whole bunch of lives after you and so
when you kind of move past this lifespan
bias and zoom out you can make decisions
differently and also those like you said
continue those little things that day to
day kind of drive you nuts they're crazy
they're stressful these short-termistic
things like no longer matter as much
well certainly humans and organizations
would make much better decisions if they
had the perspective that you described
here uh thank you for brightening our
entire future brightening my day reading
your book uh if someone wants to support
your work learn more aside from buying
long paths uh what can they do so for
yeah first and foremost read the book
and by the way you can buy it and it's a
very very short Pleasant read it's a
short Pleasant read it's not meant to be
this thing that you buy and you put on
your shelf and say one day I'll get to
it this is meant to be consuming like
one or two days and create the shift now
or start getting you towards that
buy the book or borrow the book from a
friend or borrow from the library right
there's there's a book plate in the
beginning part of the book that has
multiple lines because it's meant to be
passed on passed on generationally or
among other people right so that's how
we move from being our seeing ourselves
as a singular to part of a chain of
something else right so right from the
get-go I'm hitting you with this way of
thinking after you've read the book or
if you don't want to read the book
and this was enough for you go to
longpath.org sign up for our newsletter
we're starting to do these things called
long path gathers where people are
coming together in different cities we
were really kind of starting to ramp
that up before covid obviously ramped it
down now we're ramping that up so you
can go you can sign up there
um and those are just look and by the
way if you don't want to read the book
if you don't want to sign up for
anything and you're like this was enough
I saw the podcast I listened to watch it
just think next time you're faced with a
decision whether it be macro huge or
very small just ask yourself is what I'm
about to do making me a great ancestor
is it helping both the here and the now
and the long term and if and if you
can't answer it by the way it's not a
binary it's not a yes or no but then
change how you're going to make that
decision so that you impact the far
Futures based on your decisions because
even those smallest decisions actually
matter they matter for the person across
from you and they matter for the long
term because those will reverberate
hopefully for tens of thousands of years
well I I see it as my life's work to
just try and make the future better and
you have uh given me new insight as to
what that actually can mean I'll tell
you I personally fall into kind of a
logic
that was approach but the fact that
you're right that we need to actually
inspire and instill awe and make a kind
of of an emotional empathetic appeal
about what the future can be and who's
going to come after us I thought was
really awesome and invaluable and I
learned a ton from you awesome Ari
Wallach long path becoming the great
ancestors our future needs an antidote
for short-termism and host of an
upcoming PBS show so if you guys are
into PBS shows on on the future a brief
history of the future comes out when uh
fall 2023. well a year from now but of
course because of you we can think long
term thank you very much Ari and really
man huge fan of you and your work
awesome thank you thank you for having
me
foreign